what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we're going to
be continuing to talk about that
exclusive footage I know a lot of people
have said that they now hate the word
exclusive footage because it was only
shown to the audience at d23 and not to
the public but today we'll continue to
talk about that exclusive footage and
tell you exactly what was shown
exclusively at d23 today we're going to
be talking about the echo footage that
they showed we're going to be talking
about Daredevil Kingpin and when
Daredevil might actually show up in
She-Hulk I know everybody's been waiting
we haven't seen them yet and if you're
looking to hear about what they showed
for black panther 2 wakanda forever
Ant-Man and the wasp quantumania and
Loki 2 footage you can check out the
videos I did yesterday and the day
before and of course if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest news
so Echo is kind of going to be taking
place at two different points in time
during the series they did confirm that
it is indeed going to be an origin story
but at the same time it is going to take
place after the events of Hawkeye where
we were introduced to Echo so I'm
assuming it's going to be like one of
those shows that kind of do flashbacks
to different points back in time maybe
kind of like the eternals but hopefully
a bit more organized because obviously
we have to talk about what happened
after Hawkeye especially with Kingpin
and if you have not seen the Hawkeye
series and you are trying to avoid
spoilers we're about to get into them
well one I guess I talked about already
but if you haven't heard that Kingpin is
now in the MCU then I would be really
really shocked throughout the Hawkeye
series Maya was seen as the leader of
the tracksuit Mafia and then of course
it was revealed that Kingpin was her
boss it was also revealed that Kate's
mother was working for Kingpin the
entire time as well not necessarily by
choice but she was now at the time
Kingpin was kind of like Maya's adopted
father Hawkeye killed Maya's real father
when she was younger and since Kingpin
had always been around even when Maya's
father was alive since she was was a
baby he kind of just took her in as her
father however Maya slash Echo
eventually learned that it was actually
kingpin's fault why her father died so
of course then Maya sought answers from
him and then she sought revenge and
ultimately by the end of the series she
got that Revenge as the last shot that
we saw of Kingpin was him getting shot
in the face by Maya now everybody
assumed that he was dead but of course
this was taken directly from the comics
well almost in the comics he actually
gets shot in both eyes but in the MCU it
looks like he only gets shot in one
we'll get to that in just a bit
regardless Kingpin is going to be the
main villain of the echo series and then
he's going to go into the Daredevil
series which we'll talk about right
after we go over the echo footage the
echo footage shown at d23 starts with
echo on her motorcycle while we hear an
old man providing context over her Trek
he begins by explaining our ancestors
were powerful while he says this the
scene cuts to a flashback of an
indigenous tribe we then hear the voice
say they their strength Echoes through
you and this could definitely be where
Maya got her code name Echo in fact I'm
assuming it is now we eventually see the
person of whom the voice belongs to it's
a character played by Graham Greene it's
one of echo's Elders and could perhaps
be her grandfather it is not made
entirely clear who this is during the
footage that was shown but he gives her
a prosthetic leg with decorations on it
that mean warrior she signs to him that
she needs to go home from here there are
some quick action scenes in their
intercut with clips of indigenous people
and then the teaser ends with Kingpin we
see him with a bandage on one of his
eyes and he looks at Maya and he says
it's been a long time and that was the
footage that was shown for Echo at d23
now like I said it's a little bit
different from the comics because it
appears that Kingpin only has a bandage
and only got shot on one eye not both
now also from some clips of the trailer
it does seem like Maya could have some
sort of indigenous power from her
ancestors as it did look like there was
some type of magic involved in some way
shape or form so that'll definitely be
really really cool to see and it's
definitely going to explore the
indigenous background and roots of the
character now mixed in with all of that
is going to be the story of Kingpin and
of course Daredevil is going to be an
echo as well in fact during the d23
presentation something that was really
cool that happened was when the cast
came out for the echo series eventually
Vincent d'onoprio came out of course
because he's playing Kingpin but when
the rest of the cast got off of the
stage he stayed on and then Charlie Cox
came out to talk about Daredevil born
again thus confirming what we basically
already knew Kingpin is going to be the
main villain of Daredevil born again and
speaking of that title it's actually
quite interesting this may not be a
continuation of the Daredevil series on
Netflix as Charlie Cox himself a couple
of days ago came out and basically said
they're starting fresh they're starting
Anew here's what he said in a recent
interview with extra and Kevin feige was
there as well he said it's a season one
not a season four so it's a whole new
thing which I think is the way to go if
you're going to do it again do it
differently so this is not a season four
like it's kind of been rumored to be but
of course d23 showed us how rumors go of
course but it kind of seems like it's a
reboot he calls it a brand new thing but
also check this out perhaps Charlie Cox
might not actually be totally right
about that because when he was asked
about the plot of Daredevil born again
this is what he said I haven't seen a
script my feeling is based on the title
born again I think that the sense is it
is a new beginning it is going to be
different it is going to be totally
different it is going to be new stories
and new ideas so Charlie in a sense is
claiming that he doesn't actually know
he's just assuming based off of the
title born again which does indeed make
sense but even today there are some
insiders stating that it is indeed going
to be a continuation of of the Netflix
Daredevil series The Insider account The
Watcher recently said is Born Again
season 4 of Daredevil no did the events
of the first three seasons happen of
course I'm not sure why the idea of a
soft reboot is so mind-bending to some
of y'all The Suicide Squad by James Gunn
is not a sequel to the 2016 film however
the first film clearly still happened
expect something similar here and that
makes sense it's a soft reboot not a
full reboot so expect a lot of new stuff
with a little bit of old stuff in there
as well maybe some hints some nods maybe
some Easter eggs to the old Netflix
series which is honestly I think going
to be pretty cool so of course Daredevil
will be in his own series born again
he's also going to be in the Echo series
but of course he will be appearing in
She-Hulk as well and a lot of people
have been asking me when exactly does he
appear well Marvel Studios five days ago
gave us a mid-season sneak peek and I
have to say sadly it doesn't look like
Matt Murdock is going to be showing up
in the next episode of She-Hulk it
seemed seems like the next episode of
She-Hulk is really going to focus on
titanium and the fact that she's suing
Jennifer Walters over the name She-Hulk
which apparently Titania trademarked in
this mid-season preview we see plenty of
shots of Titania at a specific event
that Jennifer Walters is also at and we
see the two of them fighting I'm
presuming that in tonight's episode
episode 5 this is primarily what we are
going to see I do believe that Daredevil
will come though in episode 6 and
possibly be teased at the end of this
episode episode 5. I will say it does
look like Daredevil is going to be
pretty dang awesome in She-Hulk we even
see a scene of him in this taking off
into the sky using some type of Jetpack
system not sure what they'll do in the
MCU as far as how he got this technology
could it possibly be Tony Stark's
technology could he have made it himself
I'm excited to see where this story goes
so maybe we'll get it tonight maybe
we'll get a teaser for Daredevil in
tonight's episode of She-Hulk but I'm
expecting him to really come into play
in episode 6. but the great news is
he'll be returning an echo and then
he'll be getting his own Series so we
have plenty of Daredevil to come Echo
also looks like it's going to be pretty
dang good with Kingpin being back in it
as well and I'm really excited to see
how She-Hulk plays out so let me know
your thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below please don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest news
and theories for live updates you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof